tell me about the joy of playing music
after this long explain the joy to me
where where is it well I don't know um I
don't know what every musician you know
if I go and see you two or if I go and
see Beyonce and I don't know what their
experiences because I can't tell I know
that I'm like holy crap that's a show
and I see all the joy they bring to
people but I was talking to Ben from
Preservation Hall about what it is about
music and Orleans that I'm trying to
figure out what it is and I guess in
like weird way it's it's a bit what jazz
is it's a bit also what music is in
Africa and what I drawn to that what
music is not in Ireland almost but and I
was trying to say what is it that what
do you how do you describe that that you
can just go into a room and there's no
plan you know it goes kind of like this
now let's play it how is that or there's
no music and we don't have a plan for
what's gonna happen and then we just
make music and it happens how what what
is that about New Orleans and he goes Oh
freedom and this we said it's its
freedom and so when when the music is
when we're playing and it's perfect and
I'm like I don't even know what's
happening it's like an agreement and
everybody's free and everybody's know
nobody's playing their parts because
it's all we're just imagining at the
same time everything is being made up
together that is like freedom it is like
just making a noise together and the
noise sounds perfect
and it feels perfect and that is best
description
but it connected with something that you
understand instinctively from their
career it is it's something that when
it's perfect
it's like and it's not always because
sometimes I'm like oh I know what's
happening you know I get that but the
moments that it's perfect
that it feels perfect it's when it's
like being lifted out of your body it's
like you're not there anymore
and it's so it feels so good and I want
it it's like I was in Africa visiting
and and they were dancing around the
fire and the women were singing and
playing drums and the men were dancing
around the fire and the music is so
transformative it's it's it's ancient
music it's 50 songs that are 50 thousand
years old and but they're also new
they're they're old but they're new
because they're not happening there yeah
it's in the bill it's in the space and
it's so good and then you see it's like
it's like it's like that it's like a
acknowledging a bird song you know it's
like it's the it's think connects us to
the earth the way we should be connected
to the earth all the wires and all the
plugs and all the all the speakers and
all the lights it's it's when we when we
are transformed as a way to be
transformed by our humanity and what
connects us and that's what I want to be
part of